you
one site on mega innovation right Frank
the Chinese do have a name for
innovation yeah now David you were part
of the original investment team actually
in in $0.10 way back when we first met
in 97 actually yeah and I hate to say
David was an intern for me well it
followed him but beyond that I used to I
used to crash your couch that's right
long story but for any students that are
wondering how you ever get to China you
need to find someone with a couch and
even if they don't necessarily want you
on the couch you need to stay as long as
you can until you get a job and that's
exactly how I ultimately got the 10 cent
was through the graces of Duncan's couch
I think air B&B has some clones in China
yes it's time there you go so you I mean
really joined I mean as we've heard this
morning actually people were talking
about we sin they're also talking about
a leap a we're gonna be you know
exploring some of how this came about
but Tencent really is is sort of I mean
you joined when I think there were 24
people in the company about 45 yeah a 45
sorry I went to 24,000 here so right now
you're you're 24,000 in yeah right now
as well now you're here in Palo Alto
your feet blocks away yeah so I Mason
Palo Alto I've been part of the
executive team for a long time and I
guess yeah just to really briefly try to
explain my role sure been part of the
executive team from the beginning and
then I I'm like the that's the very
beginning I was like the non Chinese
person in the tense and executive team
so the token lawan yeah wow I and I'm so
I felt like I was always going to be the
token la whaai no matter what no matter
how good my Chinese was or whatever no
matter how friendly I was with China
Mobile shaking hands every day you
married a Chinese woman that's a
starting point yeah but so I figured
well let me take advantage of the fact
that I'm not trying to use it I'm
probably never gonna master it like a
Chinese person so instead of saying inch
engine I very early on 2001 I moved out
here and I just always have saw my role
as trying to inject very unconventional
ideas into our executive team making
people uncomfortable trying to push us
to do things that we may not have
otherwise a lot of doing and if I feel
like the
like the ideas are getting stale and I
always try to make my self heard so
there's there's no actually good title
for it I'm just called senior executive
vice president I used to be called the
international guy but I put your title
in Chinese apart from LA why so
mythology is juicing food on-site
relator right say okay so that's me
thank you yeah if it sounds amorphous
that's because it kind of is sometimes
because you were in really from the
beginning I mean you know 45 people is
pretty much the beginning you were able
to kind of create this role and and
create this as you said you were you
know offering challenges I guess to
orthodoxy or you know yeah so you were
kind of part of the furniture from the
beginning of the company in a way yeah
that's right yeah so that's different
from a Chinese companies have grown
quite big and then thinking about
international you've always had that
international strange yeah so let me
just explain yeah talk more if you don't
my so I I think this is really where
we're going but it's taken so many years
to get there you know something that you
think will take three years sometimes
takes 10 we've sent with the internet
you know people got very excited about
Internet the bubble in the late 90s and
then took a while to really kind of
fruition so I think the same is kind of
this the case for Chinese
internationalization and $0.10
internationalization things that I
thought would take three years are
taking more like 20 years but they will
happen and when they happen they happen
in a very big way just like we were kind
of disappointed in 2000 the internet
didn't happen the way everyone expected
but now our entire lives are really
being structured by the internet so
these things do happen to me was very
simple $0.10 in the future and other
Chinese companies like Alibaba and Ali
pace should be a little bit like the way
we view Samsung or Sony or Nintendo and
these great prints I mean China that
have kind of really become accepted
worldwide I think when like my kids play
a Nintendo Wii they'd only think of it
as a Japanese device and they don't
really think of it as Nintendo they
think this is an American brand or it
doesn't matter and I'd love to see the
point where Chinese companies get there
we're we're kind of just another great
brand and then maybe when people ask
themselves why why is this product so
good they're like oh because it's
Chinese because the Chinese guys do this
they're really good and that comes later
right when you ask why is Sony so great
oh they're really good you know so we're
cooking they're they're yeah anyway so
that's the dream I think it
increasingly that seems like something
that's happening now but it takes time
but one of the challenges of emerging
from China is the China is so vast and
so big why bother you know even trying
in you know a place where you don't have
a home court advantage right I mean this
has been definitely case for some the
state-owned enterprises like China
Mobile which has a small percentage of a
company in Pakistan it's tiny but in the
internet perhaps things a bit different
yeah well so why even try boy you know
sometimes it's just vision it's like
this is personally what I felt really
strong about as a vision for me you see
I thought it was very simple like China
was closed off from the rest of the
world pretty much this is objectively
speaking until 1978 and then it's been
emerging onto the international scene
increasingly rapidly since 1978 and the
only reason why you don't have all kinds
of great successful Chinese corporations
around the world now it's just because
they're kind of catching up late you
know everyone starting from 1978 it was
a closed economy and so for myself
getting involved in China it was very
clear that it was just a matter of time
before China was like everyone else with
all these amazing companies around the
world it was kind of artificially cut
off that it's just taking more time but
a very important factor to add to that
is the scale of this economy is no joke
I mean we all know that the numbers 1.3
billion people if you can be successful
in China you're gonna have very
significant capital scale very
significant users very significant
experience you know like when we iterate
in China we're dealing with all kinds of
demands across the country with all
kinds of users and often the users don't
have the kind of per capita income that
they have here so we have to be really
thoughtful about how we do things and
plus our model is really based on us
charging our users for services as $0.10
this is something that's very unique for
any Internet company around the world we
do not make money from ads in the way
that other Internet companies do we're
about 10% a driven for the most part
that's been the case for a long time so
90% of our business is based on people
actually being willing to pay us that's
a very profound point if we get I'm the
valuation of tenzin today I think is
north of 60 billion US dollar yeah I try
not to let you don't look but that's
significant orth of Facebook which is
struggling to find a an advertiser yeah
and I don't think many people have
really looked into our model so I felt
like well we're building a lot of
experience in this area
with a lot of scale because we're in
China and that leads to large capital
scale
and I think at some point that's going
to be very useful for all kinds of users
and all kinds of markets around the
world we just have to really focus on
meeting the needs of the users around
the world much more directly and that's
kind of where we're going to take it
pretty seriously like getting into the
minds of users you're saying you even
like go into their homes with their
permission
no yes that works yeah I don't know of
any case of about there for me well so
if you were just trying to understand
like how Tencent operates as a company
you know we have to think about what
could I say that would cut across every
product and everything we do as a
company of we we have something that we
call customer engagement it's a kind of
an operating methodology or almost a
culture at $0.10 it's pretty simple at
the end of the day is you know every
product manager knows that they're the
way that they make decisions has to
involve very deep customer feedback in
very deep iteration with users and the
thing that makes us different than maybe
typical Silicon Valley companies that
are really into like data mining
business intelligence a be testing
that's all great stuff we do that too
but we really feel it's important that
product managers engage directly in
face-to-face interactions with their
users you have to like no clients the
hand of the person you're serving you
have to go like if we're a restaurant
it's like you're working for McDonald's
you got to go into your restaurant you
got to watch people eating the burgers
you got to eat your own food you got to
see are we really living up to our
commitment here sometimes with Internet
companies because of the way that we
develop our services and we engineer
them with computers and we disseminate
them a lot of companies kind of lose
that touch with people and it's kind of
dangerous over time because for us some
of our services have hundreds of
millions of users some of them are well
over 500 million of users 500 users and
if we grow by 1 million users in a day
you're desensitized to it it's like oh
we grew by a million but I was hoping
for a million point five well that's a
million users how do we actually scale
things down sometimes to like the
individual really carrying about the mom
communicating with their kid the kid who
rides a bicycle 45 minutes to go to the
internet cafe how do we keep our eye on
the the big picture but also like at the
micro level and we find that we do that
there's a lot more personal satisfaction
for people working at Tencent about what
they do because you can be really
disappointed I wanted to get a million
users today and instead I only got
800,000 I missed my
targets but or you can just focus on the
one person whose life you changed right
and that's also very that that's really
what it comes down to the other day so
we try to make sure that people have a
deep personal appreciation for what
they're doing and that's really the
operating a ethos the reason we're
trying really trying to understand this
secret sauce of Tencent and innovation
and also Ali pay and Alibaba is just the
numbers I mean let's take a step back so
you started very much I guess an instant
messaging client was sort of the first
public face of of QQ perhaps but you
were able you know to surf that wave in
Internet market like games for example
which has become your now dominating in
China which is one of the largest
drivers of revenue in the Internet and
now with WeChat and other products into
the mobile world so there seems to be
something that you're doing right but
maybe you want to recap a little bit
that that trajectory and how that came
about like all of our well yeah does
anyone here use like a 10 cent service
I'm wondering like just then we use
WeChat thank you that's really not using
any chat so well so a lot of people say
even in our executive team there's some
debates like some of this seems like
we're doing everything and it's kind of
true I mean we're gonna post everything
on the internet um
and how does we do by companies right
you tend to do well we tend to build
internally we didn't release mints
bought some but usually like our
executive teams way of thinking how am I
going to expand is usually by putting
engineers behind the prop right usually
and that's very different than other
executive teams that might feel like you
know they're just gonna spend money to
but that's not how we makes you I mean
so that makes you unpopular because
startups and China want to get bought by
Tencent but yeah what can happen listen
I think yeah I don't work on that part
of the business but they should by all
means you know approach whoever but
don't do there's anything were posted
necessarily but the most important part
of any deal or any services we we really
strive for platform integration so we we
started with instant messaging as you
mentioned maybe there's a couple of QQ
users in the audience here but you know
we start with QQ and then we we know
notice that we had a very deep
relationship with the user on average
users were in queue for about four hours
a day and we started thinking that's a
lot how can we yeah how can we give them
more it wasn't really about competing
with other people
in fact $0.10 very rarely thinks about
competing with others although the media
likes to see a good fight but for us
it's like we're just thinking how do we
add more user value and then sometimes
when we expand it upsets people and we
get it I mean that's fine but but
basically we start with instant
messaging and we kept thinking about how
do we add more value to users
you mentioned the entrance into games
entering in the games is very simple for
us we were we used to be the most
favorite thing for people to do at
internet cafes until about 2002 and then
we noticed that people would go in and
send instant messaging messages to their
friends and then they'd go play games
for like four hours and then they would
leave they would send a few messages to
their friends and they were out so we
got like 10 minutes of time and the
games got like 4 hours of time or three
hours of time so we felt like this was
actually potentially very disruptive to
our business because we weren't
providing a lot of value compared to the
game companies so we started thinking
what can we do to get users in the games
and we approached games very much from
the perspective of games being an
interactive platform we weren't very
interested in art or design or this kind
of stuff single player games we were all
concerned about multiplayer games giving
the QQ users who are always
communicating with each other it's
something more to be more interactive
context to interact with each other and
then best just grown to where it is
today where it's a very big business I
think every additional service light
games that we have done have always been
informed by just a very pretty
straightforward decision thinking about
how we can add more value to our users
and and can we can we integrate that
service with other parts of our platform
to provide a really valuable offering
and why well you don't
buy companies very often although you do
you do invest and you have a philosophy
again getting behind the founding team
is really important for us I think so
there's been a lot of questions that I
get you know sometimes from friends or
people in the industry like what are we
going to do next in is $0.10 gonna buy
some big company or something because
we're how many people here in politics
is about 50 year and you have Boston we
have a small team in Boston yeah we have
we have some other you know numbers some
of us are indeed less investment or is
it yeah yeah so I mean I think that
probably
most notable investments we've done in
the u.s. is with a coming called Riot
Games which operates extremely
independently kind of to your point
about us leaving operations to run
independently but the ultimate
philosophy is we look for great founders
that we can get behind as a company so
we feel like we're most effective when
we find a really powerful smart
entrepreneur you know founding team with
a great vision that we're all so excited
about and we get behind them to support
and when that founding team doesn't need
us to be involved they're running the
show we're not like trying to interfere
in their daily operations and that kind
of stuff but when they ask us for
support we try to be very aggressive
it's trying to always part of the
equation or often not know like so when
we do investments in the US China is
often not necessarily the most important
thing at all yeah I mean now as a
company we're just trying to expand
internationally so in this model works
really well like work with founders that
are focused on the US market we get
behind them and that's how we feel like
we have a greater opportunity for a
success is by letting that founder team
you know go after the local market in us
supporting them and you've also made
investments in more mature companies
like in Russia DST milder yeah who are
backed Facebook and Zynga no but yeah
that's it's early in the day like like
say a company is going after a certain
part of the market and we get behind
them with an investment or maybe even
you know like a majority investment we
want to make sure they share our
sensitivity to users remember I was
talking about with that whole customer
engagement stuff like do they listen to
users are they really sensitive to users
do they have similar maybe different but
but similar operating processes that
share our care about the users like
that's really important to us because
then we know like when they face a
difficult decision or they're developing
their products that they're doing it in
a way that we're very comfortable with
and they kind of share our DNA even
though they're reflection of that DNA
the way they do it may be different than
us but I think that's that's a really
important part of getting behind any
operating team that's how we actually
allow them to be very independent
because we know they're gonna do things
in the right way you said earlier that
you you know you've acted always just
have challenged the Orthodox thinking
and things like how do you sort of
disseminate that through the company do
you bring well I don't know if anyone
else would agree with it
baby they would say I'm not very
effective but yeah there's no easy way
probably you cycle people from Shenzhen
through here and yeah yeah yeah we have
nothing formally but people visit here
all the time
okay usually it's when I go back and I
do like some internal talks with our
staff for certainly in our executive
meetings people will expect something
kind of outrageous from me sometimes
like that's kind of my role is to make
some outrageous claims like we see more
outrageous people hopefully coming
through the Chinese education system as
well we talked earlier you have this
ability to to get a lot of engineers on
certain products but in terms of such a
sensitive issue to talk about the
changes I actually I'm the Chinese
education system at one of our internal
meetings recently and this was the part
of the talk that really got everyone so
excited because I think there is a sense
in China that people would really like
to see more innovation the education
system because I think it's I wasn't
educated in China but I spent a little
time in Asia it's pretty good we'll show
that way yeah but you know there's a
sense very top-down and that the
top-down approach is not conducive to a
lot of like open lateral up you know
it's kind of bottom-up thinking in there
changing that because even though the
formal class is the same all the kids
are on QQ right so and they're doing
stuff I think the education system is
remarkably resilient to that the
interesting thing is that the kids that
are getting the top-down education right
annoying some people by talking about
this but I'm sensitive to that but but
you know they they go home and if
they're you know if they have access to
Internet then they're getting all kinds
of information from other sources so I
think you are getting you know a blended
model but I just think this is a great
challenge for China overall because I
think you know China's next big
challenge is to come up with the next
iPad the next space X rocket but not
just personalized design yeah I mean to
actually be the apple of the future like
I'd love to see you know Tencent
evolving in that kind of position or
maybe you know a peer company like
Alibaba I think that's where we need to
go is to truly do what do we call
products or services that blow people's
minds but maybe hadn't been seen in any
similar form around the world and people
would love these services and I think
that's how it's great for China it's
great for the world I think
that's how China really gets to the next
step of development but how do you get
there how do you get another Steve Jobs
how do you get someone with that kind of
vision and I think you need to give them
the space to do kind of crazy things
somehow and I don't feel like the
education system honestly gives
typically gives people that kinds of
space I have a music program of mine in
in Sichuan Province province in the Jeju
just Anika teach on the Jeju the
earthquake zone it's kind of a
philanthropy project of mine I wanted to
teach people rock and roll music and I
mean it's going now but there's been a
lot of challenges just to give the kids
a chance to play music you know give
them an hour a day or an hour on the
weekend to play guitar I bought like I
don't know like 50 or 100 electric
guitars and all these drums and bass is
probably on table but it's like it seem
like there's a real issue there what the
teachers giving the kids enough time I
think they get some time but it's like
it's kind of like often they're not
really given any time to call assist and
I'm trying to dig in like what's going
on it's like oh it's got all its you
know the high school exams before that I
thought I was doing the right thing the
junior high school in the Jeju they
still I mean and all I want these kids
to do is just like experience the love
of music you know rock out have a good
time that's what I did when I was their
age and it seems like it's a real
challenge because it kind of conflicts
with the top-down priorities of the
government and I'm like you know I think
you need a little bit of both I think
you need a lot of you know stringent
highly disciplined education but at the
same time give the kids a chance to make
their own me I just want them to make
their own music not like study someone
else's music
yeah come up with their own songs and I
think when China gets that balance right
it's gonna be super powerful because you
know the mathematics and all like the
science capabilities of the country is
absolutely incredible I think like
Shanghai has like the number one school
in the world now or something like that
but you combine that with like
creativity that's also very innate to
just a job so you know I'm gonna be
amazing
so that's what I'm looking for these are
the kind of things I'll share inside Ted
said that'd make me kind of crazy so
you're getting a taste right okay next
thing you can bring your electric guitar
yeah we'll hold your questions I hope
you asked for yeah
you